dramatically the vodka sends it to  Leonard Leonard now Jay and it's good  the season that he had last year for the  Toronto Raptors is Leonard to green lock  down the three is good from Vancouver  right it's a beautiful set up that time  by Kawhi Leonard trifecta Leonard in the  paint step through left-hand name Kawhi  Leonard with the finish which makes  complete sense you know that's right  [ __ ] took the passion for basketball in  the northwest and Leonard with the steal  and a foul thousand three draft and  LeBron James came out of high school but  then Carmelo Anthony he left school  early after winning a national  and seniors in high school and making  them part of the USA Pascal senior  national team program and we are now  bringing our expertise along with the  edge EE that would greatly affect the NC  double-a clearly I don't know if they  realize how much so but I can tell you  every kid in Canada the Toronto Raptors  had a basketball